Tiskari täällä, kyllä se niin on, että minä en laita hirvittävää likasia, aivan superlikasia tavaroita diskikoneeseen.
Kyllä ne täytyy ensiks puhdistaa paperilla, ja jos se on oikein likane, niin ottaa vähän jotain yleispuhdistusainenta, mutta, että laittaa.
Erittäi likasee ja rasvasee, muitten astioitten kanssa.
Ei, käy. Kyllä täytyy vähän telkkarissakin näyttää, että se ensiks pyytää. Sitten vasta laitetaan. Kiitos.
Luis, jakson tiskaukset hoidettu. Tutusti totean jälleen, eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan.
Tässä olemassa liikutaan ainakin roskien liikenteen ja eläinten parissa.
Tämän loppukesäisen puolituntisen mielipiteet on laskenut kohdilleen koiviston Lauri.
Yksi kansalainen ehdottaa kirjastoihin jossittelupistettä.
Toisen mielestä eduskunta on täynnä vaattureita, ja kuullaanpa myös syy poliisivankilan olemassa oloon.
Tipolaasiaa, vaan kaimallani Laurilla.
No, Lauri täältä Tallinnasta soittelee kansanradioon.
Tota, sellaista asiaa, että EM-yleisurheilut ja Ylen studiotiimi, niin pakko sanoa sellaista, että se asiantuntija Tuomas Rajaniin paljon on saanut negatiivista palautetta, ja potkujakin siellä vaadittu.
Mutta, mun on sanottava, että aikamoinen positiivinen ilopilleri, ja hän, tuntuu, ettei kukaan muu ymmärrä, mutta hän ymmärtää, että kyllä ne suomalaiset siellä on tehneet parhaansa. Kiitos.
Terveisiä vaan tuokille, täältäkin studiosta. Kohta vaidamme aihetta, kun vuorossa on pari puhelua roskiin liittyen.
Sitä ennen kerron, että meille kansanradioon voi lähteä Whatsapp-viestejä, sekä äskeisenlaisia äänimuotoisia, että myös tekstikommentteja.
Kansanradion Whatsapp-numero on 0, 4, 4, 5, 5, 1, 5, 4, 6, 4.
No niin, meitä, käyttäjiä opettetaan koko ajan ja terotetaan, lajittele oikein.
No, eihän meistä kaikki lajittele oikein, eikä välitäkään lajitella oikein.
Mutta toivoisin näille tuotantoyhtiöille, jotka markkinoivat tuotteitaan, että heidän pakkauksessaan olisi kyllin selvästi ja riittävän isolla kirjoitettu lajitteluohje, koska on niin monenlaisia pakkausmateriaaleja, että ei niistä tavallinen kuluttaja saa millään selvää, että mihin ne lajitellaan.
Pyrin lajittelemaan oikein, ja keräilen tuolta muidenkin jätöksiä luonnosta, niin koittakaa nyt helpottaa edes niitten ihmisten lajittelua, jotka haluavat lajitella.
Tämä kaikille näille tuotantolaitoksille ynnä muille, ohjeeksi, että emme roskaa tuota luontoa turhanpäiväisesti. Voisin sanoa ihan tähän, että aamen, ja näkemiin.
Koo, vakan pehkä suulukavalta.Ni minä mieleeni pahoitikulvi tuota vanhaa maaseutun tulevaisuutta 14.8.
Ei oo vieläkään mitään tapahtunu nähi pakkausjätteen kierätys, elikkä kaupat laittaa kaikki ne muoveineen ja ylijääneet elintarvikkeet.
Hirvee ongelma ei oo vieläkään tapahtunu. Mitää? Tavainen ihminen kierrettää, vaikka kuinka paljon. Kaupalla ei oo vielä kaks vuotta ollut esiselvityty rylmä, eikä mitää oo saatu aikaa.
Tää oo pikku viljaa pitäst.Se on nimittäin joutuu pellolle, sit sitä muovietettä hynää muuta hynää. Kiitos, moi.
Moi sinnekin.Seuraavasta puheilupaketista paljastuu kommentteja viime aksoen puheen aiheisiin.
No hei, kuule, tääl on mumma, joka soittaa.
Hei, hei.
Kuule, sillä rouvolle, joka sieltä Rovaniemeltä sanotti kauppaan, ei tuoda tavaroita, niin
onkohan älynyt, tai kuka lähinen älynyt pyytää terveyskeskuksesta apuvälinettä, rollaattoria,
jonka avulla ihmisen o hyvä liikkuja, tavarat kaupasta kulkee eri, päinnapperesti.
Oletko itse toiminut näin?
Nimenomaan, itsellä on käytöstä.
No nii, eli siinä kokemus puhuu nyt.
Kyllä, ja tosiaan nii, ei tarvitse kantaa.
Ja, siinä on hyvä, pieni kävelylenkki tulee, jos ihminen kerran pystyy kävelee, niin tulee, ja siellä kaupungin kaduilla, sielähän pääsee, aina on silästyvät paikat kolkea.
Ni, ja tällä tais olla, tällä edellisen ohelmaa soittaneella, tilanne se, että siinä oli ihan niinku muutamasta sadastametristä puhuu.
Sadasta, viidestäkymmenestä metriä hän puhuu.
Juu, että kaupat on kaks kauppaa lähelle, ja kummastakaan ei tuoda, mutta tällä kennolla pääsee itse ostoksille, ihan hyviä.
Sillä kärjillä on hyvä tuoda tavarakotia, jääkaapin eteen saa tuoda kai.
Kiitos paljon tästä ehdotuksesta.
Ooo, kiitos sulle. Moi.
Tääl on eräs eläkeläinen myyrymäestä.
Kaikilla ihmisillä ei ole eläkeläisillä tietokonetta, ei älypuhelinta, eikä täällä ei voi maksaa mihinkään automaattiin eikä kioskiin.
Et se on hyvä ehdotus siltä mieheltä, joka fansadariossa ehdotti, että kirjastot ottais vastaan jotain eläkeläisten laskuista.
Ja sitten tämä vielä näin, että myrmäessä ei ole pankkia, ei ole maksuautomaattia, pitää mennä tikkurilaan ja tilata sinne aikaa tai pasilaan, mut sinne ei pääsee rollan kanssa.
Oletteko ymmärtäneet?
Näin.
Joo, hei.
Yritin puolustaa näitä työttömiä niini.
Olen tässä päivään ja illan aikana soittanut parille kymmenelle työttömällä, jotka ovat vielä kortistossa niini.
Ne eivät ole, joka vuosi pääsee, et ei oo kuuteen, seitsemään vuoteen pääsee työelämään.
Ja sit siellä tämmöstä, kun kertoo jostaa naisten pikineistä ja uimapuvuista riini.
Sori, kun tärkeätä riini ihmettelee, ja aika törkeätä, että kyllä kansanradio näkee, että miten se kohtelee ihminää.
Ei täällä muuta markti, täältä sörkästä ja stadista, hei, hei.
Nyt on vuorossa monenlaisia ehdotuksia, ennen puheluita yksi viesti, joka on lähetty kansanradion verkkosevojen lomakkeella.
Voisiko uimahalleissa järjestää sellaisia aikoja, että olisi tuoksuttomia hetkiä?
Ikävää, kun veden yllä leijuu vahva parfyymien ja muiden tuoksuaineiden pilvi, kuin taxfreeessä konsanaan.
Mikäli olen oikein ymmärtänyt, tarkoitus on käydä puhdistautumassa ja virkistäytymässä,
laittakaa hyvät ihmiset ne hajusteet vasta kotona, pikku pesut ennen altaaseen menoa, ja hajusteet vasta jälkeen.
Antti Pappa, niymerkki oli lähtenyt tämän tekstin, kansanradion verkkosivojen lomakkeella.
Jarmo Jyväskylästä, terve.
Terve, terve.
Minä ehdotan semmoista asiaa, kun Jyväskylässä pitää nimetä omaa katu keskustassa, Kalle Rovanperälle.
Hän nimittäin trihtasi, eli ajo autolla sivuluisussa siellä, muutama viikko sitten.
Nähän luontoihmiset nousi takajalolleen, mutta minä ajattelin, että Kalle Rovanperä, kaksinkertainen maailmanmestari,
niin tarvitsee Jyväskylässä, rallipääkaupungissa oman kadu.
Joo, että vaikka Rovanperä on aika nuori kaveri vielä, niin on kadunaan sainnut.
Ehdottomasti, tässä huumassa ja hypetyksessä voidaan sitten sieltä puuppolasta tehtaa ympäriltä nimetä vaikka isään mukaa Harri Rovanperää,
ja sitten tehtaa vetäjän, tuota, Tommimäkisen mukaan niitä pikku katuja, mutta kun riftataan keskellä kaupunkia ja ajetaan sivuluisussa, niin siinähän sitä harjoittelua o.
Selvä, kiitoksia tästä ehdotuksesta ja oikein hyvää kesäpäivänjatkoa.
Tamoi, hei.
Jampe, olis semmonen ehdotus, että Suomen jokaiseen pirjastoon semmonen jossittelupiste, missä ois ihminen, joka jossittelis sinun kanssasi asioista. Kiitos, hei.
Tääl o, Raisionukko, terve.
Terve, terve.
Ainakko toi eduskunnan kyselytunti on ja hallitus vastaa, ni sen jälkeen, kun ministeri, hallituksen ministeri on vastannu, ni voisko asia saada semmosen,
semmoinen olis toivomus senen kahren sekunnin tekonauru, joka vastauksen jälkeen, tällainen ku amerikkalaisis vilmeissäki o.
Eli eduskunnan kyselytunnille vastauksen jälkeen tekonaurua.
Pitää paikassa monen pari sekuntiaki.
Mistä tällainen ehdotus tuli miele?
No, se on jotenkin ne vastaukset, on semmosia, ette vaatis tämmöisen tekona, Uru.
Horjes.
Siiirrymme nyt kotimaista päätöksentekoa käsitteleviin ajatuksiin.
Silläkö se työttömien tilasta olinen määrä vähenee, kun kiristetään korvauksia?
Onhan näitä silmänkääntötemppuja, joka näyttää ja kuulostaa hyviltä esittäjinsä silmissä ja korvissa, vaikka totus onkin toisenlainen.
No, täältä Oulusta, lamantailtaa, ajattelija.
Viksi Suomestukki kutsutaan maailman pöytiin.
Vastaus.
Ainaha ravintolalaskun maksaja on tervetullut mukaa.
Hiitti, hei.
Mäkel arja, semmoinen asia, että tossa viimeks kansanariossa, yks mies sano sitä, että kansanedustajan, että ministereiden palkkiot pitäis perustua siihen tulokseen, mitä ne tekee siellä.
Että talataan pohjapalkka, kaks tuotta, ja sitten jo ne saa jotain aikaiseksi siellä, tekemällä jotain tämän kansan hyväksi, niinku pitäis tehdä, tehdä jotain sopimuksia, tehdä jotain semmoisia järjellisiä päätöksiä, joka tukee Suomen kansaa.
Niin, voisi olla ihan hyvä, että semmoinen tulospalkkaussysteeme, jos ollaan jossain muualla tekemässä jotain muuta hommaa, ni ei palkkaa, ja pohjapalkka on se kaks tonnia, ja siitä lähdetään.
Siis, ihan tämä on monella alalla.
Ja, en näe mitään muuta, muuta kuin, tää olis yks asia, että jos nää kulut ja menot, joka on vääristiriitaisia jollain tavalla, niin päätä semmoiseen konsensukseen siellä, että ei nyt koko ajan huudella niinku toisille, ja syytetä toisia, vaan tietä semmoisia päätöksiä, joista jotain hyötyä Suomelle.
Ei tässä muuta, se on moi.
Nä tekee uusia lakeja ittiä varte, että ne voi nostaa sitä ja tätä osinko-osaketta. Semmosta se o, siistiä sisätyötä pukuu päällä. Suutaria siellä ei, minun mielestä oo, nappaskängissähän nuo kaikki näkkyy kulkeva.
Kulkemisen siinä päätettiin.Näinpä onkin paikallaan kuulla seuraavaksi liikenneteemoja.Äänimuotoisia ajatuksia edeltää tämä kirje.Kansaradion älyköt. Me sota-ajan kestäneet stadilaiset emme arvosta tätä hallitusta. Se on Suomen huonoin ja kärkkään Sanna Marinin hallituksen haukkuja.
Orpoja purra ovat saaneet maamme köyhyysloukkuun.Totuus on niin karvas, ja yhä jaksetaan kehua omia virheitä. Kasvoa ei ole näköpiirissä. Aiheuttamanne velkaa, kasvaa ja korot nousee. Hyvinvointivaltion ovat orpoja purra saaneet tarkkailuokalle. Hävetkää.
Kansaradion kirjoitti kirjeessäni merkki Friedu Sörkasta. Meille Kasaradion voi lähtää kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postia osoitteeseen. Kansanradio PL 79 00 00 24 Yleisradio.
Karri tässä terve, kuule, oon ihmetellyt pitkään, että näitä liikenneonnettomuuksia sattuu ihan äärettömästi, päivän aikana ihan ääretön määrä, ja keli on mitä mainioin.
Eihän ei saada mitään, eikä mitään aurikko paistaa, tosi kuiva keli, että miten se on mahdollista? Ajääko nämä ihmiset sitten niin kännissä?
Tai joitakin huumeiden vaikutuksen alaisena, että näitä onnettomuuksia sattuu, koska eihän se niinku muuten teoreettisesti ole mitenkään mahdollista.
Kun ei voi keliäkään syyttää siitä. Kiitos, heippa.
Lovisosta yngve vaan hei. Mopon välittäminen ja virittäminen on ihan eri asia.
Nykyään mopoissa voi olla jopa seitsemän hevosvoimaa, mutta ne on niin tiheästi välitettyä, että ne kulkee vaan 45-50.
Minusta mopojen nopeus pitäis nostaa kuuteekymppii. Mun Solifer kulki kakkosella viiteekymppii ja kolmosella seitsemänkymppii.
Ihan turvalista ajaa kuuttakympii. Että sille, moi.
No, karpponäristu, kitteiltä, tuossa aamulla oli noista mopoloista vähän puhetta.
No, minä oon pajokka kansa, reiko 20 vuotta aion mopolla. Minäki aion sillä mopolla. Ja siinä ei ollu nii hirmune iäni. Tässä nytten pyörii tässä mopo.
Ni sinä oon hirmune iäni. Ja sä jäi joita päivää. Minä oon eläkeläinen kerrostalossa. Ni hää rinkkiä kiertää. Ja poliisi ei maha sille kuulmaa mittää.
Ni oon koloman kertaa soittanut poliisille. Ei mitää. Apu miina suanu. Jota semmoista. Moikka.
No, näistä poliisien ja mopopoikien touhoista voi kotona anneta kuria. Ni opettajille ja poliiselle kuri antoi oikeus. Ja pyärillä ja mopoilla ei keulita. Siitä pitäis antaa vähän enemmän kuritusta.
Onko poliisit toiminu siis ihan oikein tässä tapauksessa?
Ihan oikein.
Et poliiselle ei oo mitää huomautettavaa?
En huomauta. Mistää?
He ovat täysin aina oikeassa.
Ei aina, mutta minä en ole havainnut semmoista tilannetta vielä, että poliisia pitäis liikenteestä, moittia.
Poliisi pidätti sen ja mopopoika loukka sittäs. Mut mun mielestä se poliisi oli töissä ja se mopopoika oli rikollinen.
Ja poliisi ei oo rikollinen?
No, sentähden. Meil on poliisi keksitty, tää yhteiskunta, et se ottaa kaikki roitsot kiinni. Eduskunta tekee ne päätökset, ja poliisillä annettu valta, et se saa ottaa kaikki rikolliset kiinni.
Ja se mopopoika oli Chimiel rikollinen, ja sillä oli neljä eri rikos. Se olis saanu ajaavaa omaa pihalas, mut ei, se teki oo rikoksen, ku se lähtii se moponkas.
Nii, mut siis kyllä sitä poliisia epäilää törkeästä vammantuottamuksesta.
No nii, ne on katso. Sie et teadotusvälineet, ja naiselähdet, ne tekee sen asia semmoseks, et ne vapauttaa sen rikollisen ja syyttää tätä poliisi.
Vaik se oli poliisi työtä.
Ei, ei, ei, ei, tässä on nyt kyllä mikään naisteleidet tätä syytä, vaan, siis sitä poliisia epäilää törkeästä vammantuottamuksesta, joka kiilas sen mopoilea sinne ojanpientarelle.
No miksei se pysähtyny? Ei olis tarvinnu oleka kiilata, ku se olis pysähtyny silloin, ku siel annettiin pysähtymismeskii.
Eli, eli mielestäsi, tämä poliisi, jota nyt epäilää törkeästä vammantuottamuksesta, toimi oikein? Niinkö?
No se on poliisin tehtävä, et se o ottaa rikolliset tiini.
Selvä, kiitoksia tästä näkemyksestä ja oikein hyvää sunnotajatkoa.
No se o moine.
No tääl on kansan radion iki oma saputet jälenke.
Mul ois asia tästä mopoilusta ja moottorityöräilystä, ni se on kiva harrastus, että nuorilla on mopoilu harrastuksena ja voi ajella pitkin poikin tätä kaunista Suomen maata.
Nyt olisi ihan hyvä saada semmoinen asia, että poliisit sais mennä peruskouluihin kertomaan, kuinka tärkeätä on pitää se rekisterikilpi.
Mopossa, ettei tuu mitää ongelmia, koska se rekisterikilpi on semmoinen liikennävakuutuskilpi, koska liikennävakuutus on oltava voimassa.
Koska jos jotain tapahtuu, onnettomuutta, ni tuotanoi, ni siinä on sellainen tilanne, että, jos ei oo liikennävakuutusta kunnossa eikä oo rekisterikilpeä mopossa tai moottoripyörässä, ni se moottoripyörön omista ei joutuu maksamaa, kaikki kulut itse omakussista.
Mä toivoon kaikille, mopoilijoille ja moottoripyöräliölle, turvalisto loppu kesää, noudatetaan liikennesääntöjä, eikä pahemmin kuule niitä viritellä niitä mopoja, koska, jos niitä virittää, ne helposti karkaa käsistä.
Terveisin, kansanradion, iki oma SatuTädi.
Kiitoksia SatuTärille. Nyt vielä yksi sähköposti mopoilusta, ja sen jälkeen lisää kannanottoja poliisiin liittyen.
Sähköpostissa lukee näin:
Viime aikoina on saanut seurata kaikista medioista, korvat ja silmät täyteen, Tuuslan mopojuttua.
Mutta kukaan asiaa kommentoineista ei ole sanonut, miten tapahtuma olisi voitu välttää.
Minäpä kerron, mitään ei olisi tapahtunut, kun poika olisi pysähtynyt poliisin käskystä.
Näin lukee siis sähköpostissa, jonka meillä oli lähdetty nyymerkki, lain kuuliainen.
Kyle.fi.Poliisit kiilaa mopoilijan, ja aika pahan näköisesti.
Mä en tiedä, minkälaista ensiapu koulutusta poliiseille annetaan, mutta ilmeisesti hyvin erilaista ku normaalisti.
Se menee semmonen juttu, että tapaturma paikalta ei siirretä yhtään mihinkään, jos ei ole pakko siirtää.
Eikä missään nimessä ketään laiteta jaloilleen.
Ihan sisäisten verenvuotojen, murtumien, mahdollisten päävammojen takia.
Kiitos hei.
Kun ootaan, että Helsingin poliisivankila, että mihkä semmoista tarvitaan, mutta nyt mä sen ymmärrän,
kun poliisit on aika paljon törttäilynykyää, ettäköhän ne tarvii oman vankila.
Eipä tässä muuta, moro.
No nii, Lapinukka soittaa taas kansanradioon, kun tuntuu siltä, että edes poliisihallitus ei taia ottaa vakavasti näitä asioita, mitä on tapahtunut viimisten puolen vuoden aikana tai pari vuoden aikana.
Minä olen esittänyt poliisiylijohtajalle, että tehkää jokaiselle poliisihenkilölle, joka tulee töihin, huumetestien, kun annetaan nousta poliisiautoon tai lähtiä töihin.
Näin tehtii Ruotsissa viiskytä vuotta sitten, eikä ollut ongelmia poliisien huvaalassalossa tai höpötyksissä huumeissa.
Ei se tunnu ottamaan tietoa, mutta vielä tulee päivää, että silimille tullee eroilleet tämä ommanku.
Näitä hän on maa täynnä.
Täältäki on yksi suko lähtenyt, ja nyt korkeimassa oikeassa yksi juttu, ni lähtee kaks listää.
Linnarissulle, ne joutuu Linnaralua, lähellu ihmisistä kaikkia juttuja, ja keksintä juttuja, ja tuomiota hakeneet syyttämille ihmisille.
Hyvä yötä pimeynti elävopiria apureessa.
Täänen, 90 vuotta täyttä nyt, Anja Mooris Rotkamost, muisteli 90 vuotta päittää sen, tällaisella juttuilla.
Koukahan kuka on ollut 90 vuotta täyttävä vettä nyt syntymä päiviä poliisiasemalla?
Minä olen.
Ensin, Rotkamosta, Jani, Priinvataksin kyydessä, noin, kolme partia, rotuolissa istuen.
Sitten poliisiasemalla, ruuduin avusteni kanssa, kiiniturvatarkastuksessa, teräaseen halunsa pidosta reisellä paikalla, vieläpä poliisiasemalla.
Siinäpä sitten, serviteltiin poliisipaarikon johdolla, turistujen rovien takana, ase löytyi avusta ja maukusta.
Oli minun asunnon availen perassa roikkuva, pienen pieni linkku veitsi, varolinen teraseen, jonka olemassa olusta, emme tienneet ennen tätä, kumpikaan en minä, eikä myöskään alustajani.
Avustelisti huokasi armumatkalla illattaksin kyydissä, tämä yhdeksänkymmenen päivän, etto, kyllä, muistetaan.
Sain me kentran hoidettua, varsinaisen asiamäkin, tulustautumisen, kenkilöpapereita varten, jokso oli osunut suuri tähän minun yhdeksänkymmenen puolestepäivääni.
Vieläkö on villihevosia, klassikko on saanut päässäni tällä viikolla.
Hevosista ei kuulla nyt kuitenkaan asiaa, mutta monet muut eläimet saavat vuoron saapua korviimme.
Ennen sitä muistan vielä, että Kansaradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan, joka perjantai kello 21.
Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta ja tilaat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta, niin saat aina ensimmäisenä tiedon, kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Ei oo vain Itä-Suomesta, kuunneluttu suuta vilisikkojen tauvin levittämistäni.
Eikö tää ois helipompi, annan mehtä miehet töihin, tappoimen taurinkantajat ja kantamattomat.
Ois, se oo helipompi, melekkeen kun aijanteko, eikä niiden miljooni, eikä tuhansi oo, eikä satoja niitä.
Teko, että minä luulisit, että se ois kaiken avaaviin ja helipoin tehtävä.
Ehkä niitä innokuita meitä miehiki saatta syytti.
Tätä minä oisin mieltä, jotta, miten den on toista, toisen mielestä. Eppä muuta ei.
Päivää täällä Karipirkanmaalta, eh, kuuskymmentä, neljävuotias.
Tiedän tästä vilisika, tarhauksesta ja vilisijoista jotain.
Ja mielestäni nyt, siellä ollaan väärillä linjoilla, tää Esa ja, että hän on tekemässä nyt jotain, aitoja, sinne taas aitoja.
Hän menee ihan kansanraat hukkaan sitten, eihän semmoisen takana vilisijät pysyy.
Se tarvitsi olla nyt silloa, et rakennuttaa sinne noita ruokintapaikkoja.
Niitä saisi olla paljo, siellä rajalla, sillä alueella, missä ne on.
Ja sinne vilisijä kerääntyy, pikku hiljaa ei ne aidan takana pysyy, mutta ne menee niiden ruokapaikkoille.
Ja sitten meil ois siellä eläkkeellä olevia mettästäjiä, ja ei eläkkeellä olevia mettästäjiä.
Ja kaikki vilisijä tammutaan sinne paikalle sitten, sitä mukaa, kun niitä ruokintapaikkoja tulee.
Se on aina samalla paikalla, se tulee sinne uudestaan, koska ei mitä talvee lähestytää, niistä enemmän ni siellä on.
Ja vaan talvella varsinkin.Tälkää nyt heittäkää kaita rahaa hukkaa jonnekki, pistäkää vaan ruokintapaikkoja, kaikki vilisijät nurin sieltä.
Kylä ni sitä lähe, ja sinne voi sitten jonkun suurenki ja karhunki pistää samaa joukkoa.
Kumminkin näi se on, että vilisikä tulee ruuan luokse, ei essa jahinaidan luokse. Kiitos paljon hei.
No joo, täältä Markku Nummelasta soittaa, kuulin justiinsa uutisista semmoisen uutisen, että oli pakko soittaa.
On nimittäin nyt keksitty, että pistetää lisää näitä hyppypuita oraville, eikö se riitä, että se länsiväylän kokeilu jo on osoittautunut turhaksi,
Se ei ollut se asia, vaan, että nyt ne on lesä keksinyt, että tehdään tämmösiä karvaansoja sinne, jotka ero maksee rahoillaan, on nyt kyllä löytynyt hyvää käyttöä. Kiitos, hei hei.
Tuota, ihmettelee tämmöstä asiaa, kun alueellani tehti tätä rottien hävitystä.
Ja sitten oli aika paljon oravia tämällä alueella. Rotat kyllä hävisi, mutta niin hävisi myös oravat.
Voisiko rottien myrkyttäminen hävittää myös oravia? Tämä on aika kummalista, koska oravat yleensä eesää rotan myrkkyä, kiimitellää sitä, moi.
No, Anna tässä hei, me ollaan täällä nyt porukalaa Inaarissa kalareissolla, ja mä ooteltiin olla vielä sulmon tai asti, ja nyt on keskiviikko tai tarkalajattaen torstai, koska se on yli puolen yön, niin mä aloin pohtii, että kuinka paljon on kala?
Ai, että, kun siellä oli hyvää yöllistä pohdintaa. Harmi, kun tässä hommassa ei voi soittaa sitä laulua tähän perään.
Seuraavassa puhelussa emme kuitenkaan matkaa Saksaan, vaan ihan Teneriffalle asti.
Matkavalmisteluita voi tehdä tämän eläinaisen WhatsApp-viestin parissa.
Jokaisen koiraa hankkivan tuli suorittaa koiraajokortti, testi, missä selvitetään tietääkö koiran hoidosta, koiran käyttäytymisestä ja koiran eläiden lukemista ylipäätään yhtään mitään.
Täällä tavoin oli kirjoittu WhatsApp-viestiin, jonka meillä oli lähettänyt nyymerkki, koiran ja ihmisen turvallisuus ja hyvinvointi edellä.
No, täällä on nainen, Teneriffalta, ja soittelen semmoista, kun täällä ei, sanotaan, no kato, ei näy Suomen ohjelmia kaikkia, eikä paljon kohta mitää.
Kun sanotaan aina siinä ohjelman alussa, että näytetään vaan Euroopan alueella.
No, ihmettelee, että eikö tää Kanarjasaaret Espanjassa oo yhtää Eurooppaa, kun se ei näy mitään.
Mutta, tämmönen asia, että keljuttaa, ku ei näe, esimerkiksi, nyt kun tulee La Promisa.
Ei näe sitten sitä Suomen televisiosta, tämmöstä oli, kurjaa asiaa. No nii.
Kuulesso, täällä semmoista asiaa nyt, kun noin Pondin elokuvat on päränyt tossa.
Ni, ketäkin ne ovat niin epärealistisia.
Nyt o, hymmene, nukko, sarjatulijasella yrittää ampua Pondin, milla vain yks pistooli.
Ja Pondi tappaa ne kaikki, niin miten, sehän on käytäny siellä mahdoton asia niitä.
Selvä, kiitos, hei.
Moi, tääl on Helmiö ja taika.
Meil ois radioon palautetta, et sielt tulee aika hyvää musiikkii, mut vois loittaa vaikkaa välillestaa kättevästä ja nii, suomira, pienemmän.
No hei, Lauri, täälen uska, muikkunen.
Hei, hei.
Munulla on sellaista asiaa, et kiitän tuosta yleen ohjelmasta nimetää silloin päin sunnuntai.
Joo, aina tää sunnuntai aamupäivän päättävä, ohjelma ennei kansanradiota.
Joo, kyllä, se on sopivasti siinä, sitä ennen.
Ja, niinkun monet moittii näitä toimittajia, jotka kittelee ja naureskelee ja höpöstelee, niin tässä ohjelmassa niiku sielu lepää, siinä ei toimittajia hölise eikä kikattele.
Ja musiikki on todellista musiikkiä, todellisia helmiä aarteita, kun niitä kuuntelee.
Siiinä on melkei kuin jumalapalveluksessa, ois saarina kuuntelema.
Onko se musiikki niiku sitä, et se on tarpeista tuttua, vai et siinä on, siellä on myös jotakin harvinaisuuksia?
Ja, niinkä harvinaisuuksia, et ne on sellaisia, et niissä on oikeesti jotai sanomaa.
Ja, on sitä uutakin musiikkiä, mutta paljon vanhempaakin.
Nä sisältää jotain sellaista, mikä tavoittaa ihmisen, niinkun sen, ihmisen ytimen, kun niitä kuuntelee.
Nä ei ole vaan sellaista, tehdäänpä hyvää biisiä, panaisiin kivat lyrikat, vaan ne tulevat jostakin syvätään ja koskettaa syvälle.
Kiitoksia paljon tästä puhelusta ja oikein hyvää sunnuntajatkoa.
Kiitos, ja vielä kerran toi itse toimittajalle ja teille toimittajalle. Hyvää päivänjatkoa ja syksää.
Joo, toki se syksykin sieltä ajallaan saapuu, mutta tähän kesän lopulle kuulemme nyt tämän jakson runon nurkan.
Sitä ennen kerran vielä kansaradion puhelinnumeron. Se on nolla, kahdeksan, nolla, nolla, yksi, viisi, neljä, kuusi, neljä.
Ja puhelu on soittajalle maksuton. Ja muistuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello 12:30 alkaen, tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Ja turusta, hei, ole sen ni keneet, jo yhdeksänkymment täytiä.
Juhlat jäi pitämättä.
Mä olen julkaissuu aikoinaan kolme omaakustanne runokirjaa, ja haluaisin nyt tämmösen runon sinne lukea, kun tämä sopii kaikkina päivinä.
Haurasta ja särkyvää, kestävistä ihanin ja vaikein, työskennellä lasten parissa.
Teille antaisin mitalit, pystyttäisin patsaat. Pitellette käsissänne särkyvää, haurasta materiaalia.
Kovistenkin ohut panssari kiitoksen pienistä kiteistä, pureilla kuin munankuori.
Lapset, arvokkaimmat kaitista, hoitoon uskotuista, voimia jokaiseen päiväänne, ja nimenomaan lasten kanssa oloni.
Niin ihaniaako ne on, se on, niinku mä sanoin, et, samaan aikaisesti, ihanin ja vaikein tehtävä.
Hei, hei kaikilleen.
Olovi soittelee hyvää päivää, runonpatkä havaintoja elämästä.
Moni meistä joskus kuvittelee, sen näyttää ja ajattelee, minä parempi tuoda toista, vaik ei millään te ollaan.
Toimellaan, itse suuremmin näy eikä loista. Itse tuntuu vaan, sillä nostattaa, hyvää oloa itselleen, siitä kai saa.
Vaan ei haittaa ketään se laitinkaan, kukin polkunsa taivaltaa tavallaan, törveisen olani.
Vielä on ainakin aikaa mennä elokuviin, tai ainakin yrittää mennä.
Ennen viimeisiä pueluita, minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää, koiviston Lauri kiittää ja kumartaa, kansanradio jälleen viikon päästä.
Terve, ootteko viime aikoina käyneet elokuvissa?
Siis, ei herra, jumala, kuka elokuvien vihaaja on suunnitellut uuden nettisivut?
Sis, mä oon vuoden pystyny välttelee, mä käyn kaikissa muissa elokuvateattereissaan, mitä näitä nu oli?
Kiitos, tienissä pitäjissä on ihan niiden omat, mutta siis, siis, mä yritin, mä yritin varata leffaliput sieltä.
Ja onnistuin siinä, mutta ennen, ennen mä oon pystyny maksaan ne, ennen mä oon pystyny maksaan ne, että sitten mä oon vaan voinu kävellä sinne saliin.
Ni ei saakelita samassa yhteydessä, ku ne oon nyt niinku ne nettisivut tuhonnu, ihan lopullisesti, niin nyt mä en päässyt maksaa niitä muuta ku siellä palvelukassalla.
Siis, mä oon nii, tronen tästä. Kiitos, hei.
No nii, Pekka Kinnunen soittaa Jyväskylästä, asiani on seuraava, koskee urheilua.
Urheilusalostijat ja TV-kommentaattorit sanovat, että, kun joku urheilija tulee toiseksi, hän voitti hopeaa.
Tai, jos hän sai pronssia, ni se on väärin, sillä vain kulta voitetaan, ja hopea ja pronssi aina saavutetaan. Kiitoksia.
Täällä puhuu mummo Kaakkois Suomesta, nyt hän vietämme ylen satavuotisjuhlia. Sen kunniaksi ehdotan, että yksi kokonainen kansanradio lähetys omisettaisiin pelkästään hyville asioille. Kyllä niitäkin varmasti täältä Suomesta löytyy. Ja paljonkin.